In the Times of India few weeks back it said that
according to Japan in the next 20
years India will be a super
power
and its my humble
request to my dear Hindu brothers to
my dear Muslim brothers to my dear
politicians of this great country of India
it is my humble
request that you
people you should understand you should
follow the sacred
scripture go back to the sacred
scripture of Hinduism and of
Islam and if we follow sacred scripture
insha Allah God willing in the next 20
years India will be a super
power India will be better than America and
the European countries it is clearly mentioned it is
clearly mentioned in Rigveda book number 10 his
number 71 verse number for it is mentioned that
seeing the word you see not hearing the word you are not your the word
of the mighty God but you are
not you  See the word of almighty God but you see
not Allah says in the Quran in Sura Baqarah
chapter number one verse number 44 Allah says that
you read the scripture but why don't you
follow it Allah says in the Quran in Sura Baqarah chapter
number two verse number 18 Suk U F The Deaf The Dumb
The Blind They will never know the true
path and we find that the religious personalities
of most of the major religions they prevent the
followers from reading the scripture the religion
readers whether they be Hindus Muslims and
Christians they prevent the followers of the
religion to read the scripture by
understanding and given take
on Al Quran should it be
understanding and prove that the Quran was
revealed so that a person should
understand rational Mati Gad and follow the
commandment L Mati Gad the best it can to
understand Arabic lz If you understand
Arabic lz read the
translation of the Quran in the language y
Understand the best
and today we
fight even two There are different sects in
Islam There are minor differences
but the major
principle of each sect in Islam it is the same The
way different sects of Islam they
believe in one God They believe in the Quran is the
last and final lesson of God They believe in the
last and final messenger it is the same They may have
minor differences
but the major pillars are the same
And if we
analyze the reason that even two Islam has been
divided into different sects The major teachings are the same Because
Quran was revealed in
Arabic and
Arabic is a living
language There are seven hundreds of millions of people who know Arabic as a language Because
of this the Quran was Arabic
no one can change the main teaching of Quran A
great critic of Islam Sir William Mohe
says two critics of Islam He says that Quran
is the only book which remains  For 12th
century he mention this 200 years back and
today Quran is the book which has remained for 14th
century if you follow main scripture if you
understand Arabic understand the language
you understand the best the principles are the same it is
my humble
request to the Indian
government it is my humble request to my
Hindu brothers that you should revive
Sanskrit the Indian government and my Hindu
brother they should
revive the Sankrit language today
Sankrit is a dead
language you should revive the Sankrit language
and understand the scripture of Hinduism if you understand
the scripture of
Hinduism you will realize that your
scripture and the Islamic scripture they speak about the same one
God they believe in the same message and the last
final message the prophet Mohammad peace be upon him they
believe about the resurrection about life after death i would
lock two and ma talk yes n d pa
a
Do ra ive n ban nez
[Praise]
Jazakallah Thank you for your patient listening
Now we would have the question and answer
session to analyze the similarities between
Hinduism and Islam Add for la dos
present r
today In the limited time that we have
available Now we would like the following rules to be
followed during the question and answer
session Three mikes have been provided in the
ground next to the stage for the
gents one on my right and one on my
left and one mike has been provided for
the ladies in the center i.e. in the front section
of the
ladies The fourth
question would be
audible from the
slips Please stand in the queue in front
of the mikes If you wish to put forward a
question to the
speaker and speak in the mike
only don't have the mic handling assistant hand over the
mic Your question should be n  Topic
Similarity between Hinduism and Islam
Only questions not relevant to the topic
including any general questions on religion will not be permitted
Kindly state your question brief
and to the
point Only one question at a time per
questioner will be allowed for your second
question You would have to cue up at the back
of the row and wait for your second chance Seeing the
time limitation I am doubtful you may get We will allow one
question at a time on
each of the mikes in clockwise
rotation The first question from the ladies'
mic The second question from the brothers who
cue up on my right And the third question
from the microphone on my left Down here The fourth
question would be from the
slip and we can rotate in serial order in
similar
fashion Written questions on slip papers which are
available from the volunteers in the
isles and in the gang  They can be sent up
through the seating volunteers up to the stage on
my left and the Stage Management
Director had handed over the same to me in the
interest of avoiding wasting time on event
issues and to ensure a more
educative and interesting question and answer session
my decision to allow and decide questions which are left will be
final in this I would also be
assisted by the Director of Stage
Management and one of the officials from the
police who have been deputed by DCP
Mr. Hemanshu Rai kindly state your name
and profession before putting forward your question so
the speaker can give you a level
response can we have the first question
from the sisters please I am Mrs.
Rangwala you have praised Raja Ram Mohan Roy
in your talk do you know he was against purdah why does
Islam degrade women by
keeping her behind the veil is a Hindu woman
modest in her  Shalwar kame
good
qute I spoke
recently about Raja Ram Mohan Roy in this regard but now I think
about Hijab system de Ilam so aa lam ba
ve and I Hindu one does not very well
and must understand it I appreciate certain
point
of person taj na mein I agree with all
points for
apple for
back force the Home Minister of India
mistletoe
Awani only suggested that
the rape sh by put to
tooth and ate
Ilam
fis
Badwani na I have to brasat rela
Similarly Raja Ram Mohan Roy is great
rim I really respect m ils not w aa
hijab system elam
na today if we analyze the modesty level of
a human being it differs depending upon
the surrounding they live in for example there are certain
Muslim countries in the Arab lands who
set if any one looks at a woman and stay
at the woman it is considered  If you kiss a
woman it is modest In India as
you don't touch a woman you are modest There for while they
greet the ladies and the gents
they fold hands but they do touch anyone If you don't
touch a woman you are modest In some of
the western countries shaking hands is
modest If a man shakes hands with a lady it
is modest and if you don't shake hands it is
considered that you are not friendly In other
western
countries if you kiss a woman it is modest If you
go outside kissing it is modest In some
western countries as the man and
lady anything they do is they do vulgarly it is must
So different people have different levels of modesty
depending on their way they live
For example in America if a lady wears a
mini skirt and shirts she could be modest But the
same girl if she comes to India and she wears a mini
skirt and shirts we will say
modesty is not  I talked in America, the
American told me brother Zakir, do you know the
Indian woman is immodest? I doubt I agree with my mother, of course
the Indian woman is the only one who
exposes modesty
so towards American exposing the
modesty so depending on their different people the
level of modesty keeps on changing let us try
and analyze what does our creator almighty God have to speak about
modesty Allah says
in the Quran in verse number 24 30
to the believing man that he should lose his gaze
and look at his modesty Allah first
speaks about the modesty for the man and then of
the woman never a man looks at woman any breath that come in
his mind he should lose his gaze there was
a Muslim looking at girl for a long time I
told brother what are you doing it is
haram to stay at woman he told me our bold
prophet said the first glance  Aloud the
second is prohibited I have not yet
completed half my
glance what did the Prophet mean one he said the
first glance is Aloud the second is
prohibited what he meant was if you
unintentionally look at a woman do not
intentionally look at her to feast on a beauty
that does not mean you can look at a woman for 10
minutes without blinking and saying I have not yet
completed my
glance the next verse peeks about the
hijab of the woman Allah says in Surah Noor
chapter number 24 verse number 31 about the
believing woman that she should lower her gaze and
guard her modesty and display not her beauty except what appears ordinary
of and draws her veil a
head covering over the body
except in front of a father a husband her
sons and the big list of maraems who she
cannot marry is given and the criteria for
hijab is given in  The Quran and the Sahih Hadith give
basically six criteria: the first is the
extent that is for the man it is
from the navel to the knee; for the woman the
complete body should be covered; the only part that
can be seen is the face and the hand up to the
wrist; the remaining five criteria are the same
for the man and the woman; the second criterion
is the way the clothes are worn; it should not be
transparent as it could be seen through; the third is it should
not be tight fitting so that it divides
the figure; the fourth is it should not be so glamorous that it
attacks the opposite sex; the fifth is it should not be
discreet as that of the opposite sex; and six is ​​it should not be clothes which are the
science of the
unbelievers and the reason for hijab is given
in chapter 33 of 59 in which Allah
says, O Prophet, tell your wives and your
daughters and the believing
women that when ever they go abroad they should  Put
on a cloak so that they shall be raped and it will prevent them
from being
molested Suppose there are two twin sisters who are
very beautiful or equally beautiful
and if they are walking down the streets of
Bombay down the street of Peddar Road and one of the
twin sisters she is wearing the western
clothes a mini skirt and shut and the other twin
sister she is wearing the Islamic hijab
complete body covered except the face and
hands up the rest and if they are walking
down the streets of Peddar Road and if
round the corner there is a girl who
is waiting for a catch who is like to tease a
girl I must question which girl will tease it will it tease
the girl wearing the mini
skirts are shut and will it tease the girl
wearing the Islamic
hijab but naturally will tease the girl wearing
the western clothes let's analyse what do
the Hindus  Scriptures have to speak about
modesty It is mentioned in Rigveda Book number 8
him number 33 verse number 19 It says that when a
Brahmin says to a woman,
you should lower your gaze and should not look up
You should put your feet together and you should not reveal that which
the garment and the veil
conceals so Rigveda says that the woman should wear the veil They should lower the gaze
and should not reveal it Further
Mention in Rigveda Book number 10
him number 85 verse number 30 It says that anal is the
person who covers his thighs with
the garment of the wife To remove
the cloth or sex protects him Further Mention
in Mahavira's Ek Petra
Rama Se Naram Rama Te Sita T He please lower your
gaze and put up the veil Rama Ta
Veda
Books Talking about the  and o Gupta a
post Guptar is winning well Indian man is
well go up some go up many
Indian man they well cover head some k
face so ella in Hindu scrip set one should well go up it pity
Raja Ram Mohan Roy he might not ers God
wing Raja Ram Mohan Roy in told the woman should well go up
home minister Kevani then suggesting Rep. he may be the
next Home Minister Admin of
India word
[praise]
well yes brother state name and
profession salam awaikum my name is Afroz
Vasaya I am manager in private limited
company Id like to put one question it is a
common belief of the religion that God can do everything then why can he become a human being but I believe God can do anything and everything so he become a
human being
most of the ridge bd ilm they b in
philosophy now  Anthropology The mighty God has ten
forms and they live in the philosophy that the mighty God is so holy that he knows no harm coming here, he has no trouble, no
problem so I will come down in this
world and become a human being to set the rules
for human beings on the face of it it's very
good
logic but I people that suppose I
manufacture VCRs do I have to become a
VCR to know what is good and what is bad
for the VCR since I am the creator I don't have to
become a VCR I just wrote the
instruction manual that if you want to
play the VCR video cassette recorder put
in the video cassette and press the play button
if you want to fast forward press the FF
button if you want to stop press the stop
button don't drop it from a height it will get
spoiled don't drop it in water it will get damaged
Ill Right Instruction Manual Similarly
Almighty God since he is the creator of the
human beings he does not have to become a
human being to know what is good or bad
for the human being what does he do he chooses
a man among men and he reveals the revelation
and the last and final revelation for the
human beings it is the glorious Quran the do's
and don'ts if i agree with you
for the sake of argument
that almighty god can do anything and
everything so why can't he become a human being i agree
with you for the sake of
argument that god can do anything and everything that he can even become a
human being if god becomes a human being he ceases to be god because
god and human being have got
different qualities almighty god is
immortal you can't have a
person who is mortal and  Mortal at the
same time God has no beginning you human being have a
beginning you can't have a person who has a
beginning and no beginning at the
same time almighty God has no end
human beings have and you can have a person you have an end
and not at the same time it means less
so either you can have God and you can have man
you can't have a God man it doesn't make sense
human beings we require to eat almighty God does
not require to eat Allah se inra
anam chapter 6 verse number 14 the mighty God feeds everyone
but does not require to be fed
we human beings require rest and
sleep almighty God does not require rest if I agree with
you for the sake of argument
almighty God can anything and everything in the same
argument the mighty God can tell it  Allah
the moment God can never be God if I
agree God can do everything God the mighty can in justification but in justification only to be God
Allah insa ch number 40 The mighty God is never
justification but in justification only to be God Allah insa ch number
20 52 Allah insa ch number 20 52 Allah never makes a mistake God can never be God if God can in justification but in justification only to be God God can do everything by
Allah
in sara f chapter number 35 number one is that
vale Allah has power over all things its mention
places in sara baqra chapter
number verse 106 in sara baqra chapter number verse
109 in sara baqra chapter number  Number 284
inra Imran Chapter Number 3 29 in sara l
Chapter 16 77 in sara fa Chapter 35 Number
Allah
says for ever Allah has power over all
things Allah says in barj Chapter Number 85
verse number 16 the Allah is the fear of l never
intend what ever inten he can do but the mighty God will never intend telling a lie l never intend making
a mistake he will never intend becoming a human being he will only intend
things ch ar ghli hope que
next question from the brother on my
left alam awaikum my name is at
sumar I am student my quen it hindu
slurs n doing idol worship they claim just
worshipping the almighty God Id just for
concentration so according to Islam I allow this quen that
the Hindu scholars they agree that
idol  Worship is right but to consent almighty God
the idol is only used for
concentration they agree god has no images but they
use it for concentration so is it right
the Hindu scholars they have read the
Hindu scriptures and the scholars agree that almighty God has
no images but what they say is that those people who have a
lower consciousness they
require an ideal for concentration once
you reach a higher level of consciousness then idol
is not required so I tell these pundits
and scholars that those people who have a higher
consciousness they don't require it to
concentrate so we Muslims have already reached that
high level of consciousness we don't require it to
concentrate further more but once we speak
to children we have to make them understand easily if
your child ask you why do it then we
give the answer that I ma  chucky
pi it is thundering because I ma chucky pi
grandmother in heaven she is a grinding flower I told
mum in Islam we don't agree in telling a lie if it is a lie if I
tell
my son the it is thunder because I chucky pi he goes
to school he learns the thunder
due to son x of daily
tether he will start thinking my father is lying what we have to know we have to
speak the pun as well
set at lower
level i used caution at higher level we do require caution like
study lord one it is ha le na rekd i tellum
suppose we teach
mathematics in standard 2 when we teach
mathematics we say 2 ÷ 2 = 4 but the sem 2 ÷
2 = 4 remains in 10 standard remains till
graduation it even remains till PhD
the basic teaching of any subject remains the same
2  I will remain the same in respect
of the 2nd standard and 10th standard and
graduation and PhD it is very clear
that in the Vedas in the Hindu scripture
almighty God has got no images it basis you can
change your basic if someone tells me that
in standard so you can tell your son don't worry when
you reach standard 10 I will have to say I will not even to tell you that you have to correct
it so it is the duty of the Hindu
scholars to tell the Hindu that according to
the Hindu scripture almighty God has got no
images that is the basic so even at the basic
level they should preach to the followers the idol
worship is hope que the
next question fourth question
of the day and first
answer by brother Rohit Shah he is if
Islam is the religion of
peace then why does it preach the concept of
Jihad to
fighting and  Killing the Kafir in fact
Hinduism is the religion of peace is a very important question that if
Islam is a region of peace then why do I
preach about Jihad that it is fighting and
killing the Kafir in fact Hinduism is the religion
of peace there is a great misconception as far as
Jihad in Islam is concerned this misconception
is not only among the non Muslims it is even among the
Muslims they think that any war is fought by any
Muslim for any reason whether it be for personal gain whether it be for fame whether it be for
money any war is fought by any
Muslim jihad does not mean anyone is fought by any
Muslim jihad comes from
Arabic wa jada it means
to
strive against one's own nation it also means to
strive to make the society better it also means
to struggle in the battle for
self defense it also  Me to fight against
Operation Jihad basically I want to strive for it I want to swallow
and be very careful of the creed of Islam even if you cut in
our Sharia he is in the book the
world of fatwa and to Taba chabar number it in the
Quran I will waver you fi kafir into bucket
Hindu I will waver you fi kafir yalam and I will open
the
Quran and if you have Quran number it will set
you fi kafir
yul but it will come out of cut for the
contest read a few verses previous the
first two verses of Taba speaks now the peace treaty
between the Muslims and the Mu of Mecca this
peace treaty was finally broken in Mecca so
Allah said by the time reverse verse number he
gave ultimatum to the Amitabh Mu of Mecca you put thing straight
in four months time respect
wise the declaration of war and in the
battlefield Allah says to the Muslims wether you find
the Amitabh  Kafir you kill them
this verse of the Quran is talking
about the battlefield when the Muslims are
fighting for truth against falsehood against the enemy if they come
to attack you don't get scared kill them
any army general to
boost up the morale of the soldiers will say that kill
the enemy he will not say that let the enemies
go
so Quran says same as Sharia after number first jr number se
anjpan note verse number si
reply to his elation verse number sat if amish what aslam don just let them go at them
to place of
security so they will return the word of the mighty god
the most general army general today will
say that let the enemy go watch army general today will say that
escort the enemy to security that is
what the Quran
says and there are other misconceptions in Islam
that Jihad is holy war  Holi Wah in Arabic
is Harb Muqaddasah Now in the Quran it is Harb
Muqaddasah Mention no Var it is Mention in the Hadith
Holi Wah is not the translation of Jihad This
Holi Wah was first used to describe the
Crusaders the Christian Crusaders who
conquered many lands and kill thousands of people
in the name of Christianity Now today they
use this Holi Wah for Muslims is totally wrong
and unfortunately many Muslim slurs are common even they
use Holi Wah as the translation
Jihad totally wrong Lets analyze what do the
Hindu scriptures have to speak about
Jihad It is mentioned in Bhagavad Gita Chapter number
two verse number 50 Shri Krishna tells Arjun to
strive for Yoga it is good for you
Struggle so in Shri Krishna tells Arjun to
struggle in Mahabharata
Mahabharata Mahabharat speaks about the battle between
Krishna and
Pandava. Now fighting is possible only in
Quran and Bhagavad Gita Bhagavad Gita is the Holy
Scripture of Hindu epic about
given by Shri Krishna to Arjun in battle
field Bhagavad Gita from chapter number one
verse number 42 number 46 Arjun says I would prefer
dying
anonymously and without fighting rather than kill the cousin the
Kauravas the son of
this Sri Krishna replies in next
chapter chapter number two verse number two O
Arjun how could such
animosity come to your mind that you don't want to fight
you will not enter heaven how could you get such important
thoughts and weaken your hearts
Shri Krishna says in Bhagavad Gita
chapter number two verse number 31 to verse number
33 it says O Arjun you are a woman you should fight then only will you go
to heaven otherwise
you won't go and fight are two women who
fight for the  Truth in the battle
and many of the truth they speak of Quran and
Hadith and the evil number book of
Jihad chapter number 146 in which he is said to be a Mujahid in the blood he will go to
heaven
and if he win he will get the booty of this world only the same thing is
mentioned by Shri
Krishna in Bhagavad Gita chapter number 11 verse
number 37 O Arjun go and fight if you get that
you will go to heaven
and if you win the battle you will get the good
of this world only the same thing is
mentioned in the Hadith and the
Bhagavad Gita from which you will
not do it the
right thing Bhagavad Gita says you have to fight
for the truth and in this it can be called
the false thing in this if you fight for the truth then there is no
problem so citing out of cut off
time so we understand if speaking with
different types  Many
people should know how to believe in
Hinduism I spoke to me and at the moment I say
but in Bhagwat
Geeta I can know but in Shri Krishna I am talking about
fighting against these false things I set out in Quran from Quran then agree
with
Quran yes
sister my name is Saira I am teacher in your
talk you about
pillar of Iman is faith in Islam and
the similarity of it in Hindu scripture
there is any mention of the pillar of Islam in him
but now pillar of Iman is
limited in Hindu scripture
also between pillar of Islam and Hindu scripture yes
sister time does not permit to speak of all the
similarities you can speak for days together as for
pillar of Islam are concern it is mentioned in Sahih
Bukhari walam number one in the book of
Iman hadi number eight the blessed prophet Muhammad
SAW said that Islam is based on five
Principles on Five Pillars The First is
Af la ila illallah Muhammad Rasulallah There
is no god but Allah and Prophet Muhammad
Peace be upon him The Messenger of Allah The Second
is Establishing Salah Third is Zaka Charity
Fourth is Som that is Fast in the Month of
Ramadan and Fifth is Pilgrim City of
Mecca Once in Lifetime These are basically
Five Pillars The First One is About One Allah
Subhana Taala and the Final Messenger Muhammad S
Salam I Already Discuss in My Talk
Regarding the Second Pillar of
Salah The Main Portion of Salah in Islam Is
Sujood The Prostration Allah Says in the
Quran in Surah Imran Chapter Number 3 Verse 43
Mali A
Ban
Ay Baun And Pro A Praise P Pra I Him Yes
Type Pin Pik Stang Mein
Pharma S
Meaning Vi At Meaning Ang Me Part of
Body So ​​Stang
Mein At Parts of the
Body T Mis No Worship Y Sh Touch Part of Body
I Y
The best way Hindus can pray is by touching one's body, touching the
forehead, the nose, the
two hands, the two knees and the two
feet. The third pillar of Islam is Zakat.
2.5 per person. Wealth is given in charity
or charity is prescribed in the
Quran in Al Hashr Chapter 59 verse number 117. The Quran has been
prescribed so that the wealth does
not circulate only among the rich. This
is also mentioned in Rigveda Book number 10 Hymn number
117 verse number 117. Give cha to the poor and you may never know.
Today you are rich then you may become
rich and wealth circulate like the wheels of
a riyat. Same thing as
Islam Pillar number four
Saam that means fasting for the complete lunar
month of Ramadan. Abstinence from food and drink from
dawn to sunset. Hinduism has various
types of fasting.  Types of Fasting
Mentioned in Manusmriti Chapter Number Six Verse Number
24 Fasting for One Month
Fasting is Further Mentioned in Manusmriti Chapter
Number Four Verse Number 22 and Manusmriti
Chapter Number 11 Verse Number
204 The First Pillar is Hajj The every adult Muslim who wants to
perform Hajj should at least
perform his pilgrimage to the holy city of Mecca
in the month of Hajj There are various types of
Pilgrimage There is one type of Pilgrim in
Rigveda
Book Number
Three Verse Number Four It speaks about
place of worship called Ibn
Taymi Allah's place is a place
of God and it says it is in the center of the
earth and we note Mecca is the center
of the
world Veda of Pilgrim is the House of
Allah we call Baitullah the center of the
earth and further if you read in Rigveda Book  Number the
Hymn number 29 verse number 11 it speaks about the prophet
so this place of
pilgrim is nothing but Mecca and if you open
and read the Sanskrit dictionary it says ale pad means a
place of god a place of tirtha Mecca pilgrim is also
mentioned in Rigveda
book number one Hymn number 128 verse number one r in
shart the similarity between Hindu and the
pillars of
Islam yes
brother Sami Khatib I am in
business prophet Mohammad peace be upon him he has been
prophecy in 4000 old scripture of
Hinduism Veda and the
Puranas verse for doctor Jakh Nayak you believe these
books are good sense and their Hindus are alle Kitaab bad good
quiet prophet pra Veda and
scripture can we crucify you and can say
the Ahl-e-Kitab as I mention my talk it's a
word used for people of the book  Specifically
referring to the Jews and
Christians Ahle Kitab refers to Jews and
Christians Regarding your question that can we
consider Vedas and the other Hindu
Scriptures The word of God Allah says in the
Quran in 1st chapter number 13 verse number
38 Kitab In every age we have sent revelation
but by name only four revelations are given in the
Quran i.e. Zabur, Ejeel and the Quran is the same which was
revealed to Prophet Moses
Peace Be Upon Him Zabur is the same which was
revealed to Prophet David Peace Be Upon Him
Injeel is the same which was revealed to
Prophet Jesus Peace Be Upon Him and Quran
is the last and final revelation revealed to
Prophet Mohammad Peace Be Upon Him Now all the
revelations that were revealed they were revealed
only for two people and that time all
revelation before the Quran were revealed for  Dos
people and that time Quran was revealed for
the of human kind You question can we
consider Vedas and the Hindu Scriptures the word
of God since the Vedas are not mentioned by name
in the Quran we can not say for sure that God is the word
of God what we can say may be God the
word of God you ask me since Allah has
various messengers can we consider Rama and
Lakshmana as the messenger of God c Allah says
only he is the revelation on the face of the earth he is
several messengers since Vedas are
not mentioned in the Quran to be the word of God I can say may be the word
of God I can not say
for sure similarly neither can I say that Rama
and Krishna are the messengers of God I can say may be God since they are not mention by name I can not say that for sure God may be but even if
Rama was a  Messenger of God even if
Krishna was a messenger of God even if
Vedas was the word of God they were meant for
two people and for that time today whichever
part of the world you are living in you should
follow the last and final revelation that is the
glorious Quran and last and final messenger
Prem P
Apna Scrip
Ata the next question from the slip is
brother Amar
Sinha you promote inter-fate dialogues
in this do
you agree with two who say all the religious are same so do I
promote this dialogue do I agree
with two people who say that all religions are same there are various inter-fate
dialogues
going on through out the world even in Bombay
and we find that religious personalities of various
religions come on the stage and say all religions are the same a
Hindu personality comes a
religious leader and says all region is the same a
Muslim personality come and says all region is the
same  A Christian personality come and say one reason is the same I ask them a
simple question that if you agree the same then will a
Christian priest give up
faith and become
Muslim will a Muslim person give up Islam and
become Hindu will a Hindu priest give him
and become Christian the answer is in no way people give up faith
and become Muslim an image of being secular they each give one another back it is
like a student
asking a
teacher pls 2 pls 3 and it is equal to
4 and it is equal to 4 three teachers come on the
stage and say all three answers are correct pls 3 also pls also
and pls also this is nothing but because I am a
student of
Islam and understand reason I read the various
scriptures I know the practice of various
regions are not the same I believe in total
harmony I believe in interfaith dialogue I say one is all but one at least  All the
scriptures are different at least one
scripture is 100% true word of God this is
no problem personality would be different to me I would have no
mandate acting at least one author would have the right to believe at least one me at least the
Bible is the word
of God I would have no problem with at least the Vedas
the word of God the Muslim would have no problem with at least the Quran the word of God now what you do is you collect all the heads
of teachings from the
Christian Bible from the Hindu
Scripture the Vedas and from Islam the
Quran now you find the quality suppose 50 are
common now one we take 50 quality the teachings
from all the different scriptures everyone can agree this
potion of the various scriptures at least is the
word of God and no one
element it is present in scripture
this take only  Harmony by Rani
or they are the difference between the difference
in the differences I can make a
difference between them in
all the scriptures they may be some
people who may not be well versed in the scriptures they may
sometimes be offended for I point
out that all the scriptures whether the Bible or the Vedas
or the
Quran should not be worshipped as he is not aware of the Vedas he may
feel offended but yet he will not go against me because if he goes against me he
is going against
the Vedas and he is the word of God
so this is the best way for interfaith dialogue
and total harmony that come to come in terms of
us and you hope so yes
brother my name is Mubeen Solkar
and I am a liar by profession before I put in
my question I must say I am
really impressed by your knowledge of Hinduism
Scripture it's really amazing my
question to you is that you said there are so many
similarities between Islam and Hinduism does that
mean according to Islam a
person can be a Hindu what are the
points given so far between Islam and
Him
not an Islam but can be a Hindu by
definition a person is in India then there is no
problem in Islam if you are Indian and practice
Islam I am proud of my country
India and I am proud to be Muslim no
problem in Islam if you are Indian and
practice Islam but if you mean by that Hindu
a person is to read scripture of Him then I have no objection as I am a
Hindu strictly follow the entire
scripture of Him what do I mean by that because these mention
the
Hindu scriptures which have been re confirmed
by the last and final revelation  of God that
the glorious Quran and I am referring to
Vedas and the Quran in my lecture both of them they
believe in the one God they believe
in the messengers they believe in the last messenger prophet
mah Salam they believe in yer after if they
believe in illegible facts I have no
objection but if you tell me no Hindu is a person who believes in everything what he mentions in
scripture then I
being a student of comparable religion I don't agree why it is
not possible for a
Hindu to believe in all the teachings in the
Hindu scripture because many at a time the
teachings of different scripture of
Hinduism they contradict many at a time the
same scripture Rigveda they contradict them selves
Manu Smith they contradict them selves for
example one place says that I should not have
poke  One place says that you should have to make so a
person cannot follow contradicting
statements generally so what we have to
believe that even in the
Hindu scriptures certain things were spoken
by the great reformers they believe
in caste system like Raja Ram Mohan Roy
Justice RA they spoke against the
sati system that the wife should burn in the
pyre of the husband so this thing a person cannot
follow that the reason I say that as long as
the Hindus follow the absolute fact and also agree that the one
last sage one
Buddha came and he tried to purify
Hinduism of the superstition many people went against him
and how come he is coming to
purify the Vedas later on they agreed that he was
the 23 of the 24 avatars they even agreed that he
Was the ninth incarnation of Vishnu
Similarly, when you read the Scripture, it
talks about Muhammad (peace be upon him) is the 24th incarnation, he is
the 10th incarnation of Vishnu, he is the
last sage So, if the Hindus believe in the
absolute fact, believe in Muhammad (peace be upon him) as the
messenger of God, believe in one God, believe in the hereafter, there is
no problem in him
being a
[praise]
Hindu Just a minute as I close the
program, do Dr. Zakir would love to answer questions I think
for another one, two, three, four or
the rules here do not permit us to
continue I have got a tough ultimatum to
close the program If you have any further
questions on the topic and on Islam and on
comparative religions, you are most welcome to get in touch
with the IRF or attend our
lectures followed by open question answer sessions which we have after any kind of
Lecture
on Saturday at 4 PM Every Sunday at 10:30
PM for Gents and on Monday for Ladies at
PM Those who have not filled up the guest
registration slip are kindly requested
to do so at the registration counter while
leaving so that you can be in touch and we may be
able to inform you of our program
Lastly we thank Allah Subhan Ta'ala for
making this program possible on behalf of
the IRF and our organizing committees I
thank all our guests, the
press and all the professionals who have evolved in the
running of this program as well as the staff
and volunteers and all the
persons who have helped up in making this
program successful especially with the help
of Allah Subhan Ta'ala Jazakallah Assalam
Alaikum
such type of lecture by Dr. Zakir Naik
100% people our program must be
conducted more and more nice Ajay Vaidya
I have great hope  Ek jis bolte rahe manzil ka ek lamp ban jayega speaker chhan bole sarva bhasha aisi safsar hoti sam mila
request to mr dr
zakir nayak to come and in the slum area also i simply pray
to god to
almighty god that a person of his caliber if only
5 per of person in this earth are of his
caliber i think there will be no problem
in the
world b